one of the big drivers of human nature
is a desire to be consistent she looked
at gym registration data gym attendance
data volumes of Search terms around
things like quitting smoking dieting for
all these data sets she sees pronounced
spikes at the start of your time periods
beginning of the year beginning of the
month beginning of the week after
people's birthdays after public holidays
all these moments are typified by people
being more open to change so the first
thing around habit formation is you've
got to break an existing habit what
behavioral scientists do is identify
when you should time your Communications
to maximize that
someone who has had their head under a
rock for a long time and hasn't been
exposed to much Behavioral Science maybe
they're not an Advertiser or a marketer
but they've probably got an interest in
human nature why should anyone care
about Behavioral Science okay good good
question so sometimes the terminology
can be confusing so if people haven't
heard of Behavioral Science it's
essentially what we used to call social
psychology so it's the study of how
people actually behave rather than how
they claim to behave
and I would argue anyone who is an
entrepreneur anyone who works in
marketing anyone who is trying to
influence other people
should be interested in this topic
because if you're any of those groups
you're in the business of behavior
change and all Behavioral Sciences is
the study going back 130 years of what
makes for a effective Behavior change so
it's a super relevant topic
above and beyond that it is robust which
actually differentiates it from an awful
lot of business theory if you think
about some very popular business
theories they're based on elegant
arguments
and the problem with Elegance is it's
not often accurate what's great about
Behavioral Science is it's never based
on logic alone it's always comes back to
being proved by an experiment so we can
give these findings genuine
um credibility and then the final big
strength so we've got our relevance and
our robustness the final big strength of
this topic is its range so there are
literally tens of thousands of studies
so whatever category you work in
whatever discipline you're working there
are so many Behavioral Science studies
that pretty much will ever challenge
have in front of you there's going to be
an experiment out there out there that
can help you solve that challenge what
would be an example of an elegant
business Theory which doesn't
necessarily show up in practice
well I think one of the big theories
that um is prominent is this discussion
of purpose being
a successful way to drive business
growth another one actually that got
more interested in recently is every
year the pr agency Adelman produce data
on uh trust and the story that they
normally accompany this data with is
there has been a massive decline in
Trust
it's just not backed up by their own
data so it's it's quite
um it's quite commonplace the the
headline findings that businesses and
Brands subscribe to
on backed up by an analysis of the the
actual data you use an example about why
margarine isn't gray at the very start
of the book why is that illustrative
uh so there's a lovely study a really
old study by psychologist called Louis
cheskin where he was working with
Margaery manufacturers so these
manufacturers back in the 1940s are
trying to win over consumers stop them
buying butter stop buying margarine
and if he went out and directly
questioned those Shoppers they said well
I don't buy margarine because it tastes
bloody awful I don't like the taste
that's why I don't buy it
but cheskin was suspicious of this
claims data
so he set up a really simple experiment
he got a speaker and he invited local
people to come in and listen to the
speaker
and
after they'd listen to the speaker there
was a buffet ladle and part of that
buffet was
um bread and a spread on it
and sometimes people
thought they were eating bread and
butter sometimes they thought they were
eating bread and margarine
now in reality
Jessica had switched things around so he
dyed the butter gray so it looked like
1940s margarine and he dyed the Marjorie
yellow so it looked like 1940's butter
and when people ate margarine
masquerading as butter they said oh it
tastes beautiful it's wonderful when
they ate butter masquerading as
margarine they said it tasted bloody
awful
so what he showed by that was it wasn't
the taste that mad it was the color you
know what
we expect to experience is a massive guy
to what we actually experience and one
of the things that sets those
expectations is is the color and the
look of our food
so it's a really really old study but
what's interesting about it is
he recognized that a direct questioning
of consumers is really problematic
what people tell us
is often
inaccurate in terms of their genuine
motivation so psychologists say people
can fabulate you know often they try and
tell the truth
but because they don't have full
introspective insight into their own
motivations
when they give answers in focus groups
or surveys
and they're trying to be honest but
those answers tend to be misleading
so what psychologists do instead is set
up these test and control situations and
they observe how people behave and that
that tends to generate more accurate
answer
stated and reveal preferences are just
such an interesting Divergence it's
something that I've been working on at
the moment looking at the mating market
and some of the challenges that young
people face yeah and when you look at
mating preferences and you ask people
um let's say that you would ask women
would you mind getting into a
relationship with a man that was the
same height as you would you mind
getting into a relationship with a man
that was the same education level as you
would you mind being the breadwinner in
a in a marriage most of the time women
are okay with these things but when you
actually look at the revealed
preferences of the kinds of guys that
they end up going for they tend to be a
little taller a little better educated
and a little more wealthy and again this
isn't to say that women are being
purposefully deceptive nor your
margarine hating butter eating people
from the 1940s it's simply a byproduct
of the fact that we do not no there's a
few things going on
it would be socially uh when you're
asking somebody a question there are
certain sort of social mores and cues
and concerns about what people are going
to think and say about your response I
mean that the observer effect I suppose
is going to be a big deal yeah yeah yeah
I think you think you're actually right
there I think there are there are two
factors going on you're absolutely right
a bit more complicated than I was making
out I think you've got a subset of
answers where people self-edit they
think well what does society what how
can I answer that makes me look like a
upstanding admirable person in society
but then there's this bigger problem I
think of often people don't know their
own motivations so you put them on the
spot they give you loads of answers but
many of them uh are misleading they're
just possible I mean
yeah there's a what I don't know if you
read this wonderful book by Christian
Rudder called dataclism so he was the
founder and chief technology officer of
Okay Cupid and I think the the subtitle
of the book is saying like how do you
know what what no what what do what do
people do when they think no one's
looking and it's an analysis of all the
data he has on dating
which show that yeah what people
actually do is wildly different from
what they say they'll do for both men
and women yeah I mean Seth Stevens
davidowitz has been on the show twice
yes brilliant phenomenal did you see
everybody live yeah yeah so everybody
lies was the first one and then his most
recent book which is about the biggest
questions people ask and I haven't
stopped talking about it for ages and I
can't believe that I can't remember what
it's called not everybody lies everybody
lies was the one that discovered that
Indian
the country of India looks breast porn
breastfeeding yeah
um the most recent one was using uh
don't trust your good thank God for that
don't trust your good is the new one
dude you would you'll fall in love with
that book it's phenomenal but it's
basically just the same thing it's a
um
data revealing what our genuine uh
preferences are yes but a particular
subset of data because he's an argument
I think it uh is that in a focus group
or survey situation which most brands do
this is you know the vast majority of
how Brands and businesses find out about
their customers they just directly ask
them but he he says the motivation of
the customer in that scenario is to make
themselves look good in front of the
questioner so it's not the motivation is
not to tell the truth
he Compares that then with search on
Google or Facebook or Pinterest where he
says the motivations of the Searcher
when you're typing something into a
search box are completely aligned with
telling the truth because if you don't
put in what you genuinely want you're
gonna get the wrong answer so I think
you're absolutely right
prioritizing that data that people
generate when they think others aren't
watching that's really powerful stuff
okay so you've got 16 and a half
cognitive biases that form this most
recent book yeah of yours uh the first
one is habit formation why is that
important yes
yeah so
there's a there's an awful lot of work
by psychologists into habit formation
and it breaks down into two broad areas
so
the broad argument is people have so
many decisions to make every single day
they don't have the time or the energy
or the wear with all to wipe those
decisions in a fully considered manner
and therefore
um what they do as a coping strategy is
either rely on what psychologists call
heuristics pick the middle option pick
the most popular option
or they go even further and they just
repeat the same behaviors again again so
if they find themselves in a similar
situation they repeat the same behavior
they did last time they don't even weigh
up alternative ways of behaving
so
um Susan Fisk describes this as people
being cognitive misers now they have the
capability to think deeply but because
thinking is
effortful because it's energy intensive
we ration that capability
thousands decisions to make every day we
can't use that capability on every one
of them Daniel Kahneman puts it a little
bit more amusingly he says thinking is
to humans are swimming against the cats
and we can do it but would rather not
so an awful lot of our Behavior Uh is
Habitual just this repeating the same
behaviors again
that's a problem
if you as a business or you as a person
want to get someone to do something
differently because how did you get them
to change their behavior if they're not
even way up your merits compared to
their existing form of behavior
but the first thing that psychologists
identify is that there are predictable
moments when those habits are are
weakened
so Catherine Milkman for example talks
about this idea called The Fresh Start
effect
her hypothesis is that one of the big
drives of human nature is a desire to be
consistent
so many many cultures have lots of
negative language about people who are
inconsistent
so this desired consistency gets us
repeating behaviors
she then says well look when we enter
new time periods I'll link with our past
self is weakened and
we
are more open to change
so that's a hypothesis but as I said
earlier the great thing about Behavioral
Science is no one ever stops at that
stage they then look at various
different data sets and observe data
sets to try and test the idea so she
looks at gym registration data gym
attendance data volumes of Search terms
around things like quitting smoking
dieting and for all these data sets when
she plot them over time she sees
pronounced spikes
at the start of your time periods
beginning of the year as we might expect
but also beginning of the month
beginning of the week after people's
birthdays after public holidays all
these moments are typified by people
being more open to change so the first
thing around habit formation is you've
got to break an existing habit what
behavioral scientists do is identify
when you should time your Communications
to maximize that to get to get that
business effect
so if you do a uh an advertising
campaign that plays off the back of New
Year New You
that yeah that would be an example so
that would be an example um Spotify is
an example so
Spotify have discover weekly
they send you a new set of tracks kind
of a bit like things you listen to but
you've never actually listened to them
they've tried to launch that service two
or three times and it failed the first
few times because they launched the
Thursday Throwback Thursdays then they
launched it as feel good Fridays it was
only when they launched it as discover
weekly on a Monday that they tapped into
the Fresh Start effect no way yeah yeah
and they they were I think they work
with Richard thaler either to
post-rationalize it or a stimulus to
test out it if you think that one's uh
uh interesting the best example I've
seen of the freshest artifacts is from
the West Midlands
so the police
launched a intervention with criminals
which tried to encourage them to stop a
life of crime get back on the straight
and narrow so they're going to be helped
with all sorts of support to get jobs
and break that break the kind of cycle
half the people that they sent out this
they basically sent out a message saying
no we know we're on to you ring this
number and we'll help you start a new
life
sometimes they just send that out
randomly sometimes they sent it straight
after the criminal's birthday
and they saw about and be worth double
checking this but I think it was either
three or four-fold increase in response
rates when the message went out around
it was just after those birthdays so
this is a situation which you know this
is a very very hard audience to change
their behavior
even amongst hardened criminals using
this timing technique of the Fresh Start
effects can boost uh boost Effectiveness
that's spectacular that is really really
cool it's really cool and it's something
she talks about this in her paper where
she says
you know often look at institutions that
have lasted a huge time many
institutions have realized this so she
talks about the Catholic Church
it's not necessarily relying on an
existing Fresh Start they created their
own moment when people kind of sloughed
off their past self and thought of
themselves in you and therefore weren't
um hampered by bugbearer consistency so
she talks about the confessional you go
into that you admit your sins when you
come out you're a fresh person therefore
you're you're oh it's open to change you
don't feel like you're being
inconsistent hypocritical so you can
both harness this bias by targeting
particular moments but you can also
harness this bias by creating kind of
moments of
um
reappraisal what about uncertain rewards
and loyalty schemes
ah okay so
if that's breaking
a habit you've then got all sorts of
different studies into well how do you
recreate uh a new Behavior
and one of the most interesting ones is
the one you mentioned which is around
uncertain Rewards
so the initial work for this goes all
the way back to the 1930s and the kind
of archetypal mad Professor a
psychologist called a BF Skinner
and what he does in his most famous bit
of work is create these boxes so he puts
a rat into a box or a pigeon and there's
a little lever in the Box
the animal doesn't know what a lever is
so first of all it just ignores it but
sooner or later it will bump into the
lever
and then out comes a sugar drop
so the rat will quickly learn to pump
away at the lever to be rewarded with
these sugar drops rats love a sugar drop
Skinner Waits until the Habit is
embedded keep on pushing away this lever
and being rewarded with one sugar drop
he then turns off the sugar supply and
then monitors how long it takes for that
habit to decay
and it's remarkably quick very quickly
the wrap becomes bored of the lever
then he creates another set of boxes and
puts in a fresh group of rats
and the boxes are basically the same
apart from one variation now
when the rats press the lever rather
than always getting a single drop
sometimes they get nothing sometimes
they get one sugar drop sometimes two
sometimes three average is out at one
sugar drop per press but there's this
element of Randomness element of
variability
when Skinner then turns off the sugar
supply
well then the rat keeps on pumping away
at the leaf for ages The Habit is deeply
embedded
what Skinner said is if you want to
create a habit far better to reward the
behavior that you want with an uncertain
and variable reward rather than a fixed
reward
now later work by people like Shen and
Fishback have shown that exactly the
same thing happens with humans we are
more motivated by this variable reward
than a fixed one
now if you take this principle you can
then apply it to your loyalty schemes
which essentially schemes to try and
generate habitual Behavior by Your
Shopper
what uh Skinner or Sharon Fishback would
say is most loyalty schemes at the
moment make a mistake you know what most
loyalty schemes do is say you come to
our coffee shop you buy 10 coffees and
we'll give you a free one so that is a
fixed and certain reward
what they would say is you can make that
scheme far more powerful without
spending any more money by adding a
element of variability you know don't
give out a transactional relationship of
tank off is one free reward instead
give your staff the option to give out
roughly 10 of copies for free so I might
go in 20 times and not get one you might
get one every five times yeah there's an
element of uncertainty
you know that would be applying uh
Shannon Fishback study would that be the
same as the McDonald's Monopoly
stickers oh go on so what do they do
yeah there that's the um so it's just
the kind of fractions yeah you buy a
Happy Meal and on the side of a cup and
on the side of the fries I want to say
are double stickers and you peel them
off and sometimes it's a free McFlurry
sometimes it's a free whatever and then
you can also combine these together in
order to build up a Monopoly board now
if you want to go down a real rabbit
hole with this once everyone's finished
watching this episode there is an
amazing documentary on YouTube just by a
small Creator if you search McDonald's
Lottery
scam and what it talks about is when
McDonald's first released the lottery it
went absolutely wild and they were very
concerned around they were dropping I
think it was a million dollars or maybe
it was a lot of money it was like at
least hundreds of thousands of dollars
that people could win with just one of
these stickers uh so they they left one
guy one dude that used to be part of an
advertising company in charge of this so
they gave him the job of security this
guy who's always winning yeah so he gets
in with the mob he's sucks he becomes
almost like a a wannabe gangster because
he's able to deploy all of these
different and they've got a
sophisticated system it's um people that
are unrelated cashing them in in
different states using different names
using different IDs blah blah blah but
then when you actually look at where all
of the money ends up coming back to it's
within a three mile radius of his uh
home postcode or something like that and
um it's just fascinating this guy gets
away with it for ages and ages and the
way that he gets away with it is he has
McDonald's on the hook it might not be
McDonald's I think it's technically the
company that did the competition on
behalf of McDonald's because they
weren't following elements of security
correctly as well so he ends up having
something over them and then he gets
caught and then oh dude it's a really
really great story but very variable
schedule reward same thing that's
happening with social media you open
your phone you don't know how many
notifications you're going to have if
you've got any DMS from someone that's
cool or interesting or whatever it's the
exact thing that Instagram uses exactly
right about social media that if you
went onto Twitter or Facebook and there
was no knowledge of how your Tweet had
been received I think it would have
faded it would have disappeared by now
it's that excitement of not knowing
whether you get 10 Retreats or 2 or 50.
it keeps people coming back again and
again so you can see I think the
absolute power there you know the other
one on a much smaller scale and there
were some unintended consequences of
this there was a lovely example from
Sweden think of stock it was Stocker
they decided to introduce this Lottery
mechanic to their speed camera or speed
cameras you drove past and if you were
speeding you got fine and your money
went into a giant pot if you drove past
and you were under the speed limit well
every let's say 10 000 cars they took a
photo of you got your number plate and
then you were given a proportion of all
the the fines and there's some lovely
data about the average uh speed in that
in those kind of streets dropping quite
significantly wow so I think it's very
effective very effective solution yes
yeah there was I mean the only problem
with that one I think it proves the
principle but it also shows that
introducing these ideas is very context
dependent what they hadn't factored was
I think that some people would try and
game the system so they found that some
people just kept them driving around
around the block to go past the speed
cameras I hope they would win the
lottery so kind of worked it it's a nice
I think proof of concept that's
fantastic okay next one make it easy
make it easy so this is this is an
interesting one in the
there is an argument for you like Daniel
Coleman the people are
he so he says that people often
have the wrong mental model about how to
change Behavior so in a recent interview
he was asked what's the single most
important thing he'd learned from the
hundreds of hundreds of experiments he'd
run and he said well that's simple three
words make it easy
and he argues that
um this so the most effective way to
change behavior is to focus on make it
easy on removing friction
whereas what most people try and do is
increase motivation most people try and
make the audience desire
uh the behavior that they want to
encourage
now that's kahneman's argument
even though he's a Nobel Laureate
nothing Behavioral Science is taking
someone's word alone everything has to
be proved experimentally
and Bergen and Rogers run this wonderful
experiment with the Department of
Education in America trying to test the
idea so back in 2017
they launched this new service where
parents can sign up and they will be
texted information on how to encourage
their children to work harder
they launched the service in one of
three ways
first way is the kind of what they call
the standard way people are texting
information
and they're told if you want to sign up
for the service just click on this link
the link took them to the form 30
seconds of effort to fill in
and in that scenario one percent of
people sign up
next group of randomly selected people
texted the same information about why
the service is amazing
but this time they are told if you want
to sign up just text us back the word
start
so they've removed about 30 seconds of
effort tiny tiny bit of effort and you
get an eight-fold increase in sign up
rates
foreign
next and final scenario
another group of randomly selected
parents texted the same information
about the why the service is amazing but
they are told you are enrolled if you
don't want to be text back the word stop
and you get 97 of people enrolling so
this removal of tiny bit bits of
friction
changes the enrollment rates in this
program by 96 percentage points so it
backs up kahneman's idea that small bits
of friction can have a disproportionate
effect
but then comes the clever bit the
psychologists then go out and recruit
100 plus educational experts teachers
head teachers of illustrators
they tell those experts
the setup of their three different
scenarios and they get the experts to
try and predict what they think
the sign up rates will be in each
scenario
now those experts aren't stupid they
know that friction will put people off
so they get the direction of change
right
but they are wildly wrong in terms of
the scale of the impact so they think
that about 35 of people sign up in the
standard variant 45 or so in the
simplified 66 I think or so on the auto
enrollment so they think there'll be a
21 percentage Point change in Behavior
based on the removal of friction whereas
in reality it was a 96 percentage Point
change
so what they argue is that
experts have the wrong model of human
behavior
they underestimate the importance of
friction they overestimate the
importance of motivation and from that
they go and make the argument that this
means that many businesses misallocate
their resources to too much time and an
effort goes into motivating an audience
to want the product too little time and
effort goes into making it as easy as
possible to get the get the product
that's brilliant and I can also see from
my history running nightclubs for a
decade and a half that
some of the things that we used to do
felt a lot like pressing on the
accelerator as opposed to removing the
brake we will be doing things that would
entice people to come down as opposed to
asking the question why are people not
attending like why are people not
attending is it that we need to make it
easier for them to get from where they
are to the nightclub do we need to put
on party buses that can pick up 40
people at a time and give them a
schedule of when they just need to be
outside of their house do we maybe need
to just run that without even asking
them if they need picking up maybe they
just need to be collected that there's
going to be a bus at 9 10 and 11 from
outside of the Student Union and it will
deposit you here you don't need to sign
up in advance it's just first come first
serve and it'll always be there
something like that we never asked those
yeah that that's to me that is a lovely
example because I can imagine if you're
working in the nightclub business and
someone comes with an idea about bus
schedules you're like oh my God this guy
should have been an accountant if they
come with an amazing uh exciting
creative promotion you're like this is
the person for me what Conor says this
is almost like the kind of a Cassandra
curse it was actually the bus
timetabling thing that would have been
far more effective it should have been
working for transport of London yeah
yeah wasn't there wasn't there an
equivalent that I read about a long time
ago it may have been from you to do with
pension contributions when people got
raises
yes so there is a lovely example so the
behavioral insights team did the work in
Britain I think 2013 2012 and it's an
amazing one so up until then this is a
kind of a natural experiment you had to
do about five minutes of admin so early
2010s and then you would be enrolled in
your Company pension scheme
and when that was the case about 61 of
people in large companies were enrolled
the government then make a change which
is everyone has to be enrolled unless
they sign a form saying they don't want
to be in it so it takes about five
minutes of work to get out of the
pension scheme now suddenly within well
sorry within six months uh enrollment
rates in those companies has gone up to
83 percent
that's a 22 percentage Point change now
remember the government is spending tens
of billions pounds in tax incentives to
get people into a pension and what turns
out to have the biggest effect is not
those tens of millions billion billions
of pounds incentive it is a tiny tiny
bit of admin if you move it from having
to opt in and spend time to get into
that pension to opting out you have a
phenomenal change of behavior so you're
absolutely right that would be a massive
scale example of how these little little
bits of friction have a much bigger than
expected effect I have no idea where
I've pulled that study from but I
remember it I remember it being lurking
in the back of my mind there was also
something else to do with
um increases in pension contribution uh
you try to suggest to workers you should
give more of your pension next year or
something like that and you've got very
low levels of enrollment however when
people got a raise you said we're going
to give a higher percentage or of this
raise just a little bit less raise is
going to come to you because a tiny bit
more is going to go to the pension it
was this unseen as yet unactualized
extra salary portioned off a little bit
more aggressively into pension and the
uptake from that was way higher as well
yeah that's a great so that is a uh
Richard Taylor and shalomo but Nazi idea
called save more tomorrow and what they
talk about is this idea called present
preference bias or present bias or
hyperbolic discounting rate which
essentially means I've anyone values uh
pleasure in the now much more than
pleasure in the future
so and with the same with pain the point
being if I uh lose if I if I'm told
things that cost me five pounds now it's
painful if I'm told that Something's
Gonna cost five pounds in a month's time
it doesn't bother me you know we we act
as if there is a very steep discount
rate between now and the future so what
yeah what shalomobanazzi and thaler did
was say with these companies why don't
you set up a scheme where you're not
essentially asking people to put money
into their pension now you're saying
will you agree to put money into your
pension in a year's time or sign it or
come out automatically in a year's time
and people think well I don't care what
happens in a year's time I mean you know
that's so distant it's attenuated it
doesn't viscerally affect me and that
led to significant increases in in
pension contributions so yeah there's
this whole host advice I think what
you're getting to there is that there
are so many of these biases as long as
you can match the right one to the
challenge you have you've got these
really effective evidence-based tools to
use do you have a look at the other guys
and girls that are in your industry like
the sailors and the Sutherlands and the
shottans of the world and look at
yourselves kind of like Wizards because
you pretty much are like what it is that
you're able to do
is akin to Alchemy or Wizardry
I know well Rory something has that
wonderful phrase I mean these books it's
called Alchemy um so I I think that this
is something that is available to
everyone I mean the great thing is you
have
hundreds upon hundreds of psychologists
thousands upon thousand psychologists
working full-time running studies that
are then put into the public domain so
if you run a business you know and you
haven't got a giant research Department
well why not use the accumulated
knowledge of of all these psychologists
so I think you're right there is some
very powerful work that other people
have been created it is a crying shame
not to harness uh these studies okay
make it difficult
uh so
what I argue and make it easy is if you
want to change Behavior first thing you
should think about is removing friction
what are the blockage stopping people
put more time and effort think about
those and getting rid of them
however there are nuances to these
studies and on some occasions you might
want to add a tiny bit of a friction in
so
if you want to change someone's
perception of the value of your products
if you want to make people think this is
a a premium worthwhile product then
there is an argument for adding friction
so the study that's relevant here is
from Dan ariely so he comes up with an
idea called the Ikea effect and what he
does him and Michael Norton they recruit
a group of people and they show them a
professionally made Ikea box
and then they ask those people how much
do you want to bid to take that box home
with you
and from memory and I'll be a little bit
out here but let's say average bid is 40
cents
next group
same process bring them into the lab
show them an Ikea box but this time it's
not assembled it's just in pieces on the
floor and the participants have to build
themselves
these people
then spend a bit of time putting the box
together and then they are asked to put
a bid in for how much they'll pay to
take this box home
and you see a jump I think it's the
order about 60 so I think we get up to
about 70 cents it's the average bid
now what Norton and Ariel argue and they
do this test in multiple different ways
they try essentially the same thing with
origami birds lots and lots of different
experiments improve the same point but
what they argue is the more effort
someone goes to the more they appreciate
the product
so you have this slight tension if you
want to change Behavior remove friction
but if the problem you have as a
business is people think your product is
a bit crap maybe they think the quality
is the problem
well there you might want to think about
adding a small uh dash of friction
so an example of this in practice there
is a lovely study which has real world
uh implications by uh Ryan buwell
where he
creates a works with a travel comparison
site and gets thousands of people to
look at
searching for holidays
and sometimes
the results are served up immediately
sometimes there is a very small delay
and whilst there's that delay for you
know a few seconds there's a little bar
that goes round and round saying
searching out Italia searching British
Airways searching Delta Airlines
now when the two groups are asked to
report back on how comprehensive they
think the results are
the group that had the delay that see
the effort that's going on they will
rate that product as better so you can
take this study in slightly abstract
settings that ariely Norton have done
you can then apply it to your web design
or your restaurant layout you know let
people see into the kitchen so they can
see the work that's going on now you can
take some of these ideas and they can
have a very practical uh set of
implications for a brand
I use Skyscanner a lot oh yeah yeah they
deploy exactly the same thing we're
searching Air France we're searching our
Lingus we're searching KLM we're
searching British Airways are you
telling me that that's all
[__] performative
I'm saying that there is a well it if
it's not it's highly coincidental there
is a study from about 10 years ago on
travel comparison sites which shows if
you purposely slow down the site and
you've got to make sure people
uh the the effort they're going to is
visible yes then that product they've
diddled me they've bloody diddled me so
one of my old business partner for the
nightclub stuff one of his housemates is
a quantitative analyst uh freelancing
and he's been brought in by people like
Lloyd's to uh do all manner of complex
analysis that to them apparently is just
total Cutting Edge stuff whereas to him
is he can do it in his sleep he's a
smart guy and um he created a
spreadsheet he needed to create a
spreadsheet in order to be able to do
this presentation for them he's
presenting this finally the culmination
of maybe six months of work by him uh as
this consultant and he created he spent
he said at least a full day learning how
to artificially render loading bars in
Excel and he did it for exactly the same
reason
that he pressed a button and Excel just
it's numbers right he's not it's not
Computing the world it's not trying to
calculate the trajectory of the sun it's
trying to work out that how much money
is left in the bank account uh and
apparently it would just Bing it would
do it instantly but he artificially
added in this computational effort with
it with a loading bar and he even
managed I think he managed to get it to
get almost to the end and then it would
stop for about five seconds
as if it was really having to turn the
cogs of the the processing power within
the computer or whatever and then think
and then it would arrive and yeah you
can feel you're on the edge of your seat
you know you're waiting for the the
comparethemarket.com do exactly the same
thing
so you got you so you've got two tactics
I think that you can apply here you've
got make your customer go to a little
bit of effort and you've got to be
careful to do it at the right time and
not do it willy-nilly you know focus a
few moments but this is essentially like
the wine cork you know someone has to
spend physical effort getting into the
bottle it makes them feel like this is a
high premium item so getting your
consumer to go to a bit of effort boost
quality exceptions that's the Ikea
effect and then I think you've got this
other bit which is very related which is
if the consumer can see the efforts
you've gone to they appreciate it more
and sometimes that's kind of moving to
this idea of the illusion of effort now
my favorite example of that is probably
Dyson
so if you think about what is the
repeated PR story of Dyson it's the fact
that he went through
5187 prototypes before he got to his
backless vacuum
now if consumers were completely logical
rational decision makers it wouldn't
matter it doesn't care if he's gone
through one or a million prototypes what
should matter is the quality of the
product itself
but what people like Eva Morales say is
that's how people should behave but
behavioral scientists are interested in
how people actually behave and working
out the quality of a product is a very
time consuming and difficult thing to do
working out how much effort that product
has been to that is the uh much easier
to to take in and what people often do
is when they're faced with a complex
difficult calculation which gives them
an ideal answer is they almost without
knowing it replace that calculation with
a simpler and almost as accurate
question so people perhaps should be
asking how high quality is this product
because that's tricky they end up saying
how much effort do I think
that brand has gone to and they use that
as a proxy
for for quality so the argument to
service providers like your friend or to
Brands is not to fictitiously invent
efforts because most people go to them
but it's to make sure your client or the
consumer knows you've been to them be
much much more transparent make sure you
you you tell them I can't remember who
it was that I was speaking to that used
the example of bags of flour and uh
pre-cooked Breads in the windows of
Italian restaurants
oh go on yeah just that it is you know
especially if it's artisanal flower
that's been ecologically sourced from
the the hills of the Himalayas you think
oh my god look they've got the flat the
flowers out front I mean that's how you
know why would they put it in the in the
[__] window they don't even need it
in the window it needs to be in the
kitchen where it's of any youth
um but I wonder whether that's a a an
obvious display of of care about this I
also it's I'm kind of thinking about the
more cottage industry
um you know local
very middle upper class uh shop
everything's served to you wrapped in
brown paper and [__] twine you know
you know it's got one of every preserved
Jar's got one of those crisscross red
and white Lids on the top of it I just
think that all of these are little
signals of effort you know look at like
God if they if they care this much about
the twine that they've wrapped my my ham
shoulder in then surely they've gone
through the effort of this other stuff
too
so there is a whole body of work
especially people work in the kind of
food and drink there's a whole body of
work around the idea that what we
experience when we drink or eat
something is partly what we expect to
experience so it's very very important
to set up positive expectations about a
food or drink that could be through
price it could be through the way that
you serve the product the care and
attention the twine it could be the
description that you give it could be
the brand that it comes from but you've
got to set up those positive
expectations people do not
objectively weigh up the chemical
restriction to a food you know they're
eating with their mind there's a lovely
study by a Stanford psychologist called
babashiv
and he serves people five different
bottles of wine
and each of those bottles of wine has a
prominent price label
but the twist in the experiment is there
are only four different liquids one of
the wines is repeated
so sometimes people are drinking wine
thinking it costs five dollars a bottle
a couple of minutes later they have a
little sample of a wine it's exactly the
same wine but they they think it's
different and they think it costs 45 a
bottle
when shiv asks the participants to rate
the scores of those wines
they rate the
same wine that they're told is expensive
70 higher so people have a rule of thumb
in their head that if it's expensive it
must be high quality and that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
so yeah those expectations aren't just
a night and nice to have they're
absolutely crucial for a for a brand
what was the book that came out
uh about a year and a half ago two years
ago two co-authors
um
pop neuro was the website that they used
and they had you'll have 100 scene I
can't believe maybe Matt was one of the
authors names and the other guy was like
some kind of nice but Blind Side thank
you thank God yeah yeah so um yeah
really nice uh like compliment to your
your both of yours and in that they did
that example they found a study where uh
simeliers had been given one glass of
white and one glass of red wine and
they'd said look please give us the
notes and if you haven't watched Som
which is an amazing documentary on
Netflix that goes through if you want to
become a Top Flight simelier the
standard of training that you have to go
through is crushing it is yeah
absolutely insane you need to be able to
detect from the smell and sip of a glass
uh what year it is what vintage it is
not only what country it's from but
which particular region of which country
what time of year it was harvested what
amount of time it's been fermented for
every it's absolutely insane anyway they
give these somaliers
um one white one red please give us the
notes that you think oh
it's got you know moccasins and links
Africa and whatever else is [__]
coming through favorite combo and it
turns out that the white wine sorry the
red wine is just the white wine with red
food coloring in it
um and they did another one where they
had four different types of gourmet pate
and one of them was actually dog food oh
God and no one no one could pick the dog
food out no one could
um which is just insane so I think the
first thing to learn learn from this
study is if you like buying expensive
wine
get your partner to buy two bottles the
normal stuff you buy and a bottle from
littleand make sure you actually
appreciate it in a blind test otherwise
yeah well I mean that would be a
justification for just de-labeling all
of the wine that you have and then maybe
you could use variable Choice Rewards as
well especially if you have a um well I
suppose that this is what's happening
with with wine boxes in a way and all of
these at home delivery selection things
because what you're doing is
you're not quite sure what's going to
arrive you've created some constraints I
want it to be sweet I like red I like
Chardonnay I like a blah blah or you
know whether it's Gusto or any other
kind of delivery service butcher box
any kind of monthly prize giveaway uh
but you don't quite know what you're
gonna get so there is an element of
variable schedule reward and there is a
a an uncertainty around it pushes your
preconceived ideas of your stated
preferences and actually allows them to
kind of clash up against something that
you surprisingly might enjoy
yes yeah I think I think the the whole
Gusto food Box model is fascinating and
I think it's this wonderful balance of
make it easy make it hard what they've
done is uh recognize that people fall
into a rut of just cooking the same
thing again again because they don't
have the mental energy to keep on
thinking of new recipes so they make it
very very easy to have that variety
um but they also recognize that cooking
from scratch is
um uh difficult so they provide you a
little ingredients again make it easy
but they don't push it to the logical
conclusion well they don't send you is
meals that you stick in the microwave
because they know that if they did that
it wouldn't even if it tasted just as
good it wouldn't
um even if the food tasted as good from
an objective level people wouldn't
appreciate it much because you need that
little bit of effort to feel like a a
proper Chef putting things together a
bit what was that thing where you added
an egg Betty Crocker thank you yeah this
is one of Rory's right well it's a story
that inspired uh Dan Ariel and Michael
Norton to write the Ikea effect paper I
knew that I knew that Richards they have
it at the beginning of their paper and
they say look is this an anecdote this
whole story of Betty Crocker didn't sell
when it was just a instant cake mix you
poured into a tub and whisk that with
water
um and then it only took off when the
retrospectively added an extra step of
cracking an egg into it they say look is
this too good to be true is it just
marketing myth why don't we go and test
it in control circumstances amazing all
right the generation effect what's that
so generation effect uh 1970 I think
might be 1978 to Canadian psychologists
uh graph and slimeka at the University
of Toronto
recruit a group of people they give them
a long list of words the first half get
let's say catfish dog weasel elephant
they're given this list of words
then then they can read through it it's
taken away and they try and later on
recall as much as they can
next group of people
get essentially the same list of words
but rather than it being cat it's c
blank T then it's d-o blank
then it's I'm not gonna try and spell
weasel or nothing
um but it's just the uh all the words
with one or two letters missing
when that group try and recall
phrases a little bit later they remember
between 10 and 15 more
now
the psychologist's argument is that the
second list of words is more memorable
because people have to generate the
answer themselves hence the generation
effect and it's that Act of Creation
that
sticks the idea in in people's minds
so there you have this fascinating
tension again with advertising
you need to create an ad that is
um easy enough for people to understand
if they don't just Walk On By
but if you don't give any role for the
consumer then it's very forgettable
what you really want to get is this kind
of uh this balance of ease and
difficulty again
so some people have applied that in a
very pedestrian way
um you know there was a
there was an ad for cancer research I
think where it said the second biggest
cause of cancer is o b blank s blank t y
That's The Generation effect now it's a
very literal
use of a well-known psychological
experiment and it will have very
positive results it'll stick in people's
minds but when it it's done really well
is where nothing people apply these
experiments with a bit of Creative Flair
so you go back to
um
1980s 1990s and you think about the
classic Economist ad you know I never
read The Economist and at the bottom it
said management trainee age 42. now that
I think is a lateral application of the
generation effect
what David Abbott the writer of the the
poster was doing there was not directly
stating you are a failure if you don't
reach the economist
he was setting up this interesting
amusing reasonably simple puzzle the
viewers had to solve and by solving it
they're essentially generating the
answer and that makes it sticky that
makes it memorable
so you've got this literal application
by cancer research you know great ad but
where I think you get to the real
brilliant ads is when people are doing
it with this
um they're harnessing the general
Insight of the study they're not
sticking to it
um completely literally
it's that beautiful like I that that
idea the subtext of a 43 year old
management trainee somebody that is
floundering in their career they should
be further along than now uh still
there's even I don't read The Economist
or I never read The Economist there's
something kind of snooty and
self-righteous about it as well I
already don't like this 43 year old
management trainee it's just it's it's
gorgeous it's like a razor sharp
incision of of a bunch of different
memes
yeah well that's I think I think that
idea of it being multiple things at once
is brilliant so you've got this
generation effect of the audience answer
uh coming up with the uh the the
solution as it were you've got this
distinctiveness you know most brands
never go out and say do not buy me so
firstly that grabs your attention and
then I think the third and final point
is this I think we might have heard Rory
Southern say this is that often you can
get across a slightly uh unflattering or
not very nice message with a dash of
humor you know the underlying message in
the economist is a little bit nasty it's
you're a failure if you don't read our
product but they manage to say it with a
bit of charm which means that they can
convey that slightly me message without
offending people so yeah I think there
are lots of strands of that particular
ad that make it so good can you ask
questions to trigger the generation
effect as well
yes there is a uh and I think it's
aluwalia study which shows
um if you pose a statement as a question
you tend to boost credibility and
believability
however I think the
the kind of slight complication was the
success of that
depended on the
um Prestige the brand was held in so if
the brand is admired it works very well
if the brand is low status or unamired
it works quite badly what's an example
so
um I think the the sentence he has kind
of in his studies something along the
lines of you know did you know Avanti
shoes
can
um reduce osteoporosis I've not got that
quite right other times the other half
of people in the study just saw a
statement of anti-shoots reduce
osteoporosis
and he found
uh if there had been preceding positive
information about Avanti
Big Boost by using the question
if he had run some people had seen
negative information about this
fictitious Corporation the question
often backfired oh so it's mediated by
how the that's how well the brands for
see I mean I think a lot of these
questions as well if you're going to
um use a very cool slightly effortful
advert with you know some blank spaces
in or someone's got to fill it in that
for instance The Economist advert works
because the economist is an institution
it wouldn't work for Edition one of the
new businessman monthly perhaps yeah or
maybe it would it would work for both
those Brands but it wouldn't work
without uh David Abbott's copywriting
skills you know you can imagine someone
trying to pose essentially the same
point in a slightly you know pedestrian
pedestrian way in it flopping which to
me is
one thing it's worth stressing about
Behavioral Science I would always take
the approach that
these experiments are just an insights
are just hypotheses about human nature
it's just half the task what a master
and entrepreneur needs do is then take
the insight and then they need to apply
a dash of creativity
so if that sounds a little bit woolly
one of my favorite examples I've come
across a few from separate sources a few
separate sources recently is around a
creative use of social proof so social
proof is the argument that we are deeply
influenced by other people
so what most so if a brand looks like
it's popular it will become more popular
still what most brands do to to try and
harness that idea is to say we have a
million customers nine out of ten people
use our product that's the kind of
literal interpretation
what I'm saying is that's just the start
what you need to do is think about how
can you can apply this idea a bit more
creatively how can you imply popularity
without directly saying it and my
favorite example at the moment is Red
Bull when they launched
uh you like this it was around
nightclubs supposedly when they launch
they go and find nightclubs uh and then
they crush up loads of empty Red Bull
cans and stick them in the litter bins
around the nightclub so that when people
come out they see these you know bins
full with Red Bull and that's assume
that everyone else in there was
massively energetic because they had a
couple of red balls so it made it feel
like it was a popular product amongst
that that group that's applying social
proof I think in a truly truly creative
way
one area that I would love one of the
guys from Behavioral Science to get into
would be optimizing YouTube thumbnails
and titles so this is the world that I
live in right this is my currency for at
least one part of the show I need to get
people to click on the video CTR
click-through rate percentage how many
people get shown it versus how many
people click on it and watch time so
retention retention and watch time is
down to the editing it's down to the
first five to 15 seconds of the video
it's there's a number of things that go
into that but the way that not only your
title title length are you posing a
question are you using punctuation in an
interesting way are you using the
zygonic effect to create open Loops how
does this relate with the text that's
above it
um that is
if there is not a Behavioral Science
competent team applying these insights
to optimize thumbnail and titling for
larger YouTube creators
to give those insights there is a huge
agency opportunity available there
because the Mr Beasts of the world and
the pewdiepies of the world and the guys
the the absolute absolute top they will
be doing this I know that Mr Beast
spends between ten and thirty thousand
dollars on each thumbnail he has
hundreds and hundreds of thumbnail
options for every different video
um and then when it comes to titling 2
heal of reverse engineered I mean I know
for instance that the average number of
characters in the top video of your
suggested feed is going to be 44. so
it's 44 characters long is the average
number
um
the use of words that invoke a powerful
or aggressive response words like War
battle
um uh uh shock
um these are sorts of things that cause
people to click but generally I mean
this is okay both for Brands and for
creators uh is an incredibly important
thing to get right okay I have this
amazing piece of content I've worked
incredibly hard on it for a long time
and I'm being defeated by CTR and watch
time it's like I can't get people to
click on it and I can't get people to
stay with it this is one of the reasons
why uh Fast and Furious 9 if you look at
the pace of the cuts in F9 it is
unbelievably quick and if you think
about the pace at which people swipe
through Tick Tock it's like swipe swipe
swipe swipe swipe it's more than once a
second and that pace that you move at is
the pace that people are becoming used
to so Mr Beast his most recent video
where he could allow people's Blindness
by paying for their cataract surgery
that employed a new tempo of cuts within
the edit I'm not actually sure I'm sure
he'll speak about it at more length but
yeah he tweeted about it a couple of
days ago
um so that I mean he's always using eyes
to camera he's focusing very heavily on
Blues there's almost always a red
somewhere in there the use of arrows
especially red arrows is something that
causes people to click so they're all
manner of different bits and pieces
going on here that will be grounded in
stuff that probably already exists but
it's such a new
format and given that YouTube is the
number two search engine in the world
after Google and it's so high volume uh
first off selfishly I don't want to have
to try and reverse engineer this stuff
myself so someone should write a book on
it uh Behavioral Science for YouTubers
uh but also there would be it's just a
fascinating new medium to deploy all of
this through yeah so I mean that's
fascinating I think the
the behavioral biases are essentially I
think stimulus to come up with ideas to
solve some of those problems so it's the
ones that might be relevant uh there's a
lovely idea one of my favorites um
called the illusion of control
and it's by Ellen Langer who was a
Harvard psychologist back in the 70s and
he's 1975. she goes around an office
block and she
tries to sell people lottery tickets for
one dollar half the people just are
given the lottery ticket for a dollar
and they are given their numbers there's
no choice half of them get to pick their
numbers
she then Waits a week and then just
before the draw for the lottery she goes
back to the office and she tries to buy
back those tickets
now the first thing she finds is that
everyone wants more than they paid so
there's an idea called the endowment
effect once we own it we value it more
but that's not what she was studying she
wanted to know the difference in
valuation between the two groups
the first group who had no choice on
average they want eight what uh 1.96 to
sell their ticket back but the group who
got to pick their numbers they want 8.67
so there is a four-fold variation in the
valuation of what is quite obviously a
commodity
langa's argument is one of the biggest
drivers of our
of our behavior is a desire for a sense
of control for sense of agency so even
if you give someone a completely
meaningful a meaningless or Superfluous
Choice it will make them value whatever
they pick that much more now in my world
of thinking about how you get people to
buy things or change their behavior you
can take that principle and you could
apply it to your promotions so you could
say well what most brands do is say
you buy this product and you get this
reward what Lang would say that's a
mistake you should give people an option
of two things so maybe it's
a free pizza or a car wash
even if a hundred percent of people pick
the pizza there is still a value in
offering the car wash it's very present
allows people to choose and because they
have picked it they value that that
pizza more so I wonder with some of
these
um attempts doing current people to
engage is is giving the audience maybe
some degree of choice it doesn't have to
be meaningful it could be whether your
background is blue or red or you're
going to launch on a Tuesday or
Wednesday the more the more you can get
them to feel like a sense of control or
the more likely is they will appreciate
the product
the Keats heuristic
futuristic uh so that is a idea that uh
phrases that rhyme are more believable
so study done 1999 I think a follow-up
maybe 2000 by Matthew McGlone and I
think an apologism pronounced this wrong
Jessica traffic Bash and what they did
was give people lists of pseudo proverbs
so
we would both get a list of Proverbs and
on your list you might see something
like
um
what might you get
uh I don't know if you drink it will
help you think and I might get if you
drink it will help you Ponder now that
isn't actually one of their examples
that's pretty Naf but that's the
basically what they did you know it's
exactly the same sentiment for the fake
proverb but one of us gets it in a
rhyming form one of us gets in a
non-riming form
and they give out loads of these
different lists with lots of different
variations so essentially they can
compare how believable will the proverb
is when it Rhymes how believable is it
when it doesn't run and they see a
statistically significant increase in
believability in belief in the accuracy
of the proverb if someone got it in a
rhyming variation now fascinatingly
going back to what we were talking about
at the very beginning
if they say to people look you rated all
these different Proverbs do you think
you were influenced do you think you
picked the rhyming ones because they
rhyme do you think they said they were
accurate and I think it's one person in
the entire study says yeah that might
have influenced me everyone else is oh
no no definitely not
but by her dispassionate you know a
versus B test she sees rhyme does have
an effect
now I was interested in this for a
couple of reasons
like firstly I thought well that's
really interesting but advertisers don't
just need to boost believability they
also want to boost memorability
so we re-ran that study and we gave
people these long lists of fake Proverbs
it's half of which Ryan path which
didn't we then invited them back uh in
the evening if they looked at the
morning then came back an evening and we
saw people about twice as likely to
remember the rhyming phrases as the uh
non-writing ones it was about that order
I forget exactly the the swing
but what's fascinating there is you've
got this set of experiments which shows
rhyming phrases are more believable and
more memorable yet if you then go and
look at the
regularity with which businesses use
advertisers use rhyme it has been a
massive long-term decline it was a
phenomenally common tactic 50 years ago
um you know Pringles in the 80s once
your pop can't stop uh Hague in the
1930s don't be very ask for Hague you
know Mars a day helps you work Western
work rest and play you know again and
again we see Ryan being used
but if you think of the last 10 or 15
years it has almost disappeared
I did a study looking at ads over the
years and it drops to about 10 percent
so what's interesting here is you've got
advertisers or at least the people
creating the ads
ignoring a technique that is very
effective and then I think you have to
ask well why is that the case
and my
thought often drawing here on talib's
work is that
if you pay an expert and you don't
reward them
um directly so the agency is not
rewarded
according to whether you sell a product
or not if they're just given a a payment
for their uh advice what tends to happen
is it leads to complexity because if you
are a consultant or advisor you know
that if you give very simple but
effective advice you'll get five because
it sounds obvious so what what ends up
happening is you build an increasingly
complex uh model to
explain and and make recommendations
because it's that sense of
sophistication that justifies your fee
so I'm fascinated here not just by the
Behavioral Science showing the effect on
the end consumer I'm fascinated by the
fact and the uh system which means this
tactic is very very rarely used
the internal machinations of the
advertising industry are pretty
fascinating
and and you know that's the area I'm
interested in but the same would be true
I think for any service industry
um you know if you are a consultant who
sends a one-line email that saves your
com the the the company
hundreds of thousands of pounds
it will be very hard to justify a
massive fee because it looks so simple
and so easy and people will begrudge you
if you produce a 100 page report and
have
loads of people running around creating
the creating that report it's easier to
charge a large amount so there's a there
is a tension between what's up what
creates effective Solutions and what is
in the interest of the agency or
consultant who is supplying those those
Solutions was it Ogilvy that did the
thing to reduce complaints of wait times
at security at London Heathrow
oh no so I don't think so um I oh my
gosh that was uh I think I saw it first
was reported in the in the it was in the
Houston Airport I think so I think it
predates I'm pretty sure it's kind of a
story going around in in America
reported the New York Times a reasonably
thick uh accurate the
Houston Airport people were Landing uh
minute walk say to the baggage carousel
and then a a seven minute wait and after
a long flight
they got annoyed quickly and they
started to complain so what the airport
did was try and reduce the weight but
found it wasn't really possible so
rather than keep on spending more and
more money on a false errand instead of
sending the passengers directly from
passport control to
baggage carousel they just sent them on
a kind of six minute walk zigzagging
across the airport with this you know
fence laid out so they couldn't go there
directly and so people by the time they
got to the baggage carousel there was
only a minute wait and complaints
plummet and the argument was we treat
occupied weights very differently from
unoccupied whites so we're not bothered
if we're walking but if we're standing
staring uh by Pharrell then it's deeply
deeply frustrating I think Rory missed
in his transport for humans book as
something that we could have done with
regards to this that I would like way
more options on Google Maps from getting
from point A to point B for instance I
will opt to drive a route that puts me
in less standstill traffic but takes
longer to get home
if I'm going home at a time where there
might be a little bit of uh other
drivers on the roads because for me it
is existentially less painful to go a
route that takes 10 minutes longer and
maybe five miles further however one
that I know I'll always continue to move
along as opposed to being in standstill
traffic even if it's both shorter and
quicker so I would like to opt for the
route that has the highest average speed
perhaps yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that
that I uh um so I live in London it's a
far less driving because it's just
painful but my view would be to get to
another place in London it's not just
the time I'm interested in I'm
interested in the fewest possible
changes because if I have to walk to get
on a bus then change the tube then
change to another line then get on a
train
I can't sit and relax if it is a single
train which takes longer and then
there's a long walk and I've only got
one change of mode I would massively
prefer that absolutely right there is a
I think Rory's book with um Pete Dyson
it's brilliant looking at some of these
areas that all the systems that
transport providers have created
optimized to shortening time when there
are many many other factors that that
would
um make a journey more pleasant
concreteness
oh love you bye so the study here comes
from a Canadian psychologist called Ian
Begg so back in 1972 he was working at
the University of Western Ontario
recruits a group of students uh 25 of
them and we'll come back to that and he
reads out a list of 22 word phrases
now the phrases are all jumbled up but
50 of them are what he calls concrete
phrases so things like Square door or
white horse
the other 50 are what he calls abstract
phrases so things like subtle truth or
basic fact
the students read through these lists of
words
and then the words are taken away and
beg asked people to recall as much as
they possibly can
and he's key finding is the
the students remember 36 of the concrete
words nine percent of the abstract words
so there's a massive four-fold change in
memorability huge change you remember
some of these studies we're talking
about are reaching out five or ten
percent Provence this is a massive
four-fold change
his explanation is according to beg
vision is the most powerful of our
senses so if you can picture a
um a word you know if I say Square door
I squared or pops into your mind almost
unbin
if you can picture it it's sticky it's
memorable but with an abstract phrase
you can't picture it's very very
forgettable
so the tactic that Communicator should
use
is think well
work out what you want to convey to an
audience and it might be an abstract
benefit
but you have to translate that abstract
benefit into very concrete visualizable
language
so if that sounds a bit vague best
example that I know of is Apple iPods
every other brand that they were
competing with all these MP3 players
they
um
had the abstract benefit of memory that
they wanted to convey
but the way they conveyed that was in
abstract terminology you know Philips
and Samsung would talk about
215 megabytes of memory
completely abstract completely
forgettable what Apple did was convey
that same abstract benefit of memory but
using very concrete visualizable
language
a thousand songs in your pocket can
picture a pocket that makes it sticky
that makes it memorable
So currently
businesses are communicating abstract
objectives in abstract language they
need to change and translate those out
that abstract language into something
far far more concrete you need to get
customers to be able to easily imagine
using your product
yes yeah absolutely so you saw this too
oh you need to be able to get this
easily imagine your product first of all
and imagine the benefits because people
you know Samsung pre or Philips whoever
probably put a picture of the MP3 player
but people wouldn't remember the the
benefit of the 250 megabytes of memory
so Apple's genius was turning that
benefit into something that's
visualizable
there are separate studies which are
right uh there's a guy called Ryan Elder
who's come up with these ideas of
perceptual fluency
where he argues if you can get people to
imagine using your product and it's a
pleasurable enjoyable product they the
purchase intent will increase
so he did this uh bizarre study where he
shows people pictures of cake and the
fork on a plate so it's cakes on a plate
and the forks either on the left or
right and he asks people to say whether
they would be interested in buying that
cake how delicious does it look
the twist in the experiment is half the
people see the fork and left half and
the right he then questions people to
their handedness if that's a word
whether they left or right-handed and
what he finds is if the fork is in the
place where you would normally leave it
so I'm a right-handed person I'd
normally agree with the fork to the
right he uh purchase intent goes up
about 30-ish percent his argument is
you're just removing a bit of friction
you make it easier to imagine eating it
that gives you a chance to mental
experience some of the benefits that
entices you in even that tiny tiny bit
of friction
um can change change levels of of
desirability what about stories over
statistics
yeah
so the the argument here is um
I think the the study was by Paul
slovich at the University of Oregon he
came up this idea called the
identifiable victim effect which is
probably the only bias that is supported
by both Stalin and Mother Teresa
and in his study it's a beautifully
designed study he recruits people under
false pretenses so they they think
they're doing like let's say some maths
puzzles that's the psychological
experiment they finish the study and
then he says oh before you go
um read this from our sponsors it's a
message from save the children and if
you're interested you can donate some of
the fee I'll give you five dollars
whatever it was
um you can donate some of your feed to
that charity
half of the participants hear about
malnutrition in Mali
uh 100 000 people affected lots of
Statistics the other half hear about the
story of a single girl called rockier
and what slovich shows is more people
donate when they hear the single story
and they don't average more money
so his argument is it is hard to
conceptualize or visualize a statistic
now I can't picture a million people I
can't picture a hundred thousand people
so it leaves me cold but that
description of that single girl
suffering that is easily relatable that
is visualizable so I think you know a
lot of these biases you start to see you
see interlinking that one definitely
comes up in podcasting as well so when
it comes to trying to convey any sort of
Story I mean you're phenomenal at this
because every single
concept every single statistic that you
try to put across comes with an analogy
it comes with a story and it causes
people to be invested when I first
started doing this show you know when
you first came on four years ago maybe
even longer uh five years ago now
um I was adamant that what you wanted to
try and achieve in a podcast was to
ruthlessly index information and to kind
of high pressure holder into people's
ears which yeah I didn't realize at the
time but basically makes you a slightly
more conversational book summary service
which isn't what you're here for what
you're here to do is to get exactly what
can't be conveyed within a book what
can't be conveyed within a summary and
that's a Vibe so I I've taken to
referring to podcasters as Vibe
Architects like you're just here for a
Vibe and Adam mastriani who has a
phenomenal sub stack called experimental
history which you would adore uh he did
a takedown of peer review recently he uh
decided to completely pirate a study
that he'd done and just release it on
the internet in a PDF bypassed all the
journals all the peer review and just
said look you can have a look here's all
of the data you can reassess everything
just put it on put it online he's
phenomenal uh and he uh wrote a post
lamenting why we forget all of the
things that we learn you know you go
through I I made an analogy about
accounting I did first year accounting
when I did business at Uni uh and I can
remember that one of the five principles
of accounting is prudence
and I can't remember what it means I I
don't understand what Prudence means in
an accounting context the numbers are
the numbers I don't understand I don't
know what the what the other four are
but I just have this and he was like
what you have is this word sort of
floating around in the back of your mind
but what I can remember the vibe that I
can remember is getting on the bus to
UNI on the morning of the exam and
speaking to my housemate who was uh less
prepared than me and I felt very
underprepared yeah the vibe that I
remembered from that interaction and
that exam overall was wow no matter how
underprepared you think you are there is
still way further to fall and for the
most part you're going to be in the
middle of the bell curve of whatever it
is that you're doing that's the vibe
that's the lesson that I took away from
it I can't remember anything I did
uh as and a level business then a
three-year business degree and a
one-year Masters still don't remember
the five principles of accounting but I
took that away and for me that's the
same as stories you know it's the reason
that if you look at uh Morgan hausel's
the the psychology of money what a book
yeah yeah just outstanding but he's
talking about what is an unbelievably
dry topic uh for quite a lot of you know
there's only I think maybe 15 between 10
and 15 chapters or principles or
whatever might even be eight uh across
the entire book and it's a big book ish
uh
but it just Falls by because you're
learning about Warren Buffett when he
grew up and you're learning about you
know all it is is just easy easy stories
so yes that to me I James clear's Atomic
habits very story heavy David Goggins uh
never finished and uh his first book
can't hurt me also incredibly heavy uh
it's one of the best sellers it's I
think it's the best-selling
self-published book of all time uh oh
wow yeah it's terrifying but well from
self-published David Goggins to The
Iliad and odyssey there is an argument
from a classicist called uh Havelock I
mispronounced that where he says if you
look at all these stories that were once
oral stories that were passed down from
Storyteller to Storyteller by voice and
memory you go through them and what you
find is they are remarkably heavy on
concrete phrases and I think it's the
wine red sea he talks about in one of
those books uh they're very light and
attractions and the argument havelocks
makes is because abstractions are easy
to forget so when you tell me a story I
don't repeat it to my mate exactly the
same it's the concrete visualizable
elements that stick so let's say you
gave me a really abstract story and it
goes through 10 people back to you by
the time it comes back to you and we'll
probably have been refined to much more
concrete visualizable elements that's
awesome okay precision
Precision so this is a
um this is one I really like because the
the book is 16 and a half behavioral
biases that influence what you buy and I
kind of liked that title because there's
an amazing Julian Bond book The History
of the World in 10 half chapters so I
kind of had that floating around my head
and I came across a study by Schindler
Rutgers University
and in this study he gives people mocked
up ads for a deodorant
everything's the same about the ad in
two different scenarios apart from one
fact
half the people see the ad with the fact
that it reduces perspiration by 50
percent
the other half of people
get the same ad but it says it reduces
perspiration by either 47 or 53 percent
when Schindler questions all the people
as to how accurate and beliefable the
claims are
the claim well it's a precise number is
about people believe it's about 10 uh
more likely to believe it than when it's
a round number
so people believe the 53 or the 47 claim
they don't believe the 50 claim
now the argument goes that we quickly
learn in our daily life that if someone
says something in round vague terms they
often don't know what they're talking
about whereas if they talk precisely
it's from a position of knowledge so
from my perspective if you ask me how
old my cousin was I would say they're in
their 30s if you ask me how long my
brother was I would say 51. if I know
the facts I'll give it to you exactly if
I'm unsure I'll give it to you in uh
vague round terms so what Schindler then
says is people use this as a cue to
judge The credibility and accuracy of a
claim so if you want to publish an
article Don't say 10 reasons 10 ways to
become a great podcaster it should be 11
and a half or 11. it sounds like you've
picked these because they're all exactly
right whereas if you say 10 reasons it
feels like you're just trying to fit uh
the list
you know and you you can see this again
you know we were talking about James
Dyson earlier it wasn't 5 000 prototypes
that he talks about it's 5187. you know
the more precise you can be in your
numbers the more belief or they tend to
be I had Edward slingerland on the show
he is a ancient Chinese philosophy
expert uh first we're trying not to try
which is about way the uh Chinese art of
effortless action and then he wrote a
second book called drunk which is how we
sipped danced and stumbled our way
through civilization and his argument is
the beer before bread hypothesis that
civilizations came together actually to
drink because it was easier to uh do
that and one of the interesting
um justifications that he gives for why
humans enjoy drinking with each other
and why it's been such an effective
cultural technology is that it switches
off the PFC switches off the prefrontal
cortex it means that lying is more
difficult to do and
people who are under the influence of
alcohol are more accurate at detecting
lies than people who are sober
is that true wow so I completely get
uh you're going to reveal your secrets
when you're drunk but I never thought
you improve that actually that is that's
I'd love to see that experiment I'd love
to be recruited for that experiment yes
it could have been you could have been
on both sides
um but so what you have is a cultural
technology which is basically a um truth
detection enhancer and a lie telling uh
reducer so it's this very very good
um very optimal way to get people to
bond uh it was heavily used to bond
together Armed Forces for exactly the
same reason uh it's just it generally I
was really interested with that and I
think that you're talking about the
Precision of what's going on here that's
kind of like a cultural technology where
reducing the ability of somebody to lie
you know if you do if someone tries to
pin you down everyone's you know tried
to ask a friend about how come you
couldn't make it to my birthday last
week oh it was uh and it's this real big
convoluted answer as opposed to to oh I
had to puncture or I had to diss or I
did that it's you know there's always
five
intersecting reasons why and it's
because they can't come up if you know
if they're not telling the truth that is
uh as opposed to just being a thing uh
and I I think that alcohol uh kind of is
a technology that kind of does something
similar yeah well I mean that is
interesting because there's um
I can't remember I read this the there
is an argument that
why we said right at the beginning that
people often don't know their own
motivations Now you kind of think well
why surely there is an evolution
advantage to knowing ourselves really
well but the argument is if you believe
you're telling the truth uh if you are
deceiving yourself then however drunk
you get
um you're not gonna reveal the best way
to deceive everybody else is to deceive
yes yeah your your own your own hypers
or your own rubber street so they're all
and there are thoughts I think that I
think I've read this around um
hairs lies in the rabbit type thing when
they are being chased by a predator they
zigzag around but supposedly they don't
know which way they're going to go next
therefore they don't have a tell that no
way so they're joking they're juking a
prey they're giving the old San
Francisco or whatever it's called
Shuffle but they yeah so but if it feels
like very random but they don't know
where they're going left or right so no
way the hawk or whatever else is
following it can't learn it of course
and it's also going to give away no
tells because if you don't know dude
that's such a that's an amazing story
okay so Precision I'm kind of wondering
though now I'm saying it
how the hell does anyone ever work that
out so I think this is one where we
should probably go and that could be you
you kidnapped oh come back in four years
time thank you become an expert on hairs
pricing how's pricing related to
precision
so
there is some lovely work oh and this I
unfortunately I only found the follow-up
after the book had been written so in
the book I think I talk about a
University of Florida study by Janice
where they show again get a sample of
people
all shown the same items block of cheese
TV uh bicycle to some others some people
are told the price
a round amount so the TV is 500 some are
told a precise amount 505 dollars
the psychologist then asked everyone
well how good value do you think the car
is what do you think the you know the
real value of these items is and what
you find that what the psychologists
find is that when people give their
answers everyone comes back with a lower
amount so everyone realizes Brands bump
up their price above what it's actually
worth
but what the cycle should argue is
when people see a precise price they
jump down in their kind of mental
calculations in much smaller increments
so they think okay well it's not worth
whatever I said 500 maybe it's worth
4.95 no maybe 490 whereas if people uh
something if it was 505 if people see
the round price say 500 they think oh
it's not worth 500 it's worth 480 460.
so
people assume that price precise prices
are marked up more fairly than round
ones so if you as a
um a brand or a business as selling
something a hundred or a thousand pounds
you're in this wonderful you've got this
wonderful opportunity of you can
increase your price and you will
increase the desirability and perceived
um
um receive the value of that product now
that study by those two psychologies is
a slightly abstract study and you could
think well it's not really a real world
it's the lab
but what Uber have done is released
um data recently on a real world test
where thousands upon thousands of
potential customers were offered a surge
price
and some people were offered a 2X surge
price some people offered a 2.1 x search
price and what Uber found was people who
are more likely to accept the 2.1 x
price
so what Janice and you have found in a
lab study has been proven in Far More
robust and a much much larger study by
Uber there's just this sense that if
it's a round price it's probably being
pumped up plucked out of the air if it's
precise I feel that some thoughts gone
into it and people have you know only
put it up to what's really really
necessary there has to be a relation
here between reviews and statistics
around product reviews and stuff as well
um potentially I think what this would
argue yeah if you better to say you've
got
9632 reviews rather than 10 000 that
would be absolutely true
um the most interesting study I've seen
around reviews though is that a five out
of five star review is potentially
damaging
so it was a Northwestern University
study hundreds of thousands of products
000 day products
um they looked at the reviews across 28
categories and then they looked the
likelihood of people going to buy the
product and all the reviews were scored
one to five
what they found was that as the reviews
for those products got better people
were more like to purchase just as you
expect but then at some stage and it did
vary by category I think it was between
4.24.5 likely to to purchase Peaks and
then if the reviews get any better for
every category you start to see this
decline in likely to purchase
their argument psychologist's argument
was Perfection is too good to be true if
you see a product
50 reviews all of them five star out
five what is more likely that this is a
genuinely perfect product with no flaws
at all and that everyone has all enjoyed
it or there's been some funny business
going on and that brand has been you
know paying people to put positive
reviews on or editing out the negative
ones
so Perfection can be alarming for people
and they just and therefore put them off
from from purchasing rolling this across
again into my industry there is now a
five-star review on Spotify for every
podcast and there's always been one on
Apple podcasts as well and it's got a
first decimal point so pretty much every
Big Show that's not currently in a
cancellation crisis is going to be 4.7
4.8 4.9 uh yeah Andrew huberman who you
might know I might not he's an
ophthalmologist and a neuroscientist
from Stanford is so he's got one of the
biggest podcasts in the world probably
the top 10 podcasts in the world but
he's so unobjectionable that he's got a
five across the board on both Spotify
and on Apple podcasts so I actually
wonder if I should message him and tell
him that he needs to get some negative
reviews if he can just piss off a small
cohort of people he actually might end
up with better conversions if he was
more yeah I mean yes and I mean the
category it was tested on were things
like hair care and shampoo so there's
always an element of does this translate
to the different a different world but
the great thing here is
Behavioral Science in these experiments
set up
a a hypothesis to go out and test at
least consider that you would never
normally consider I mean who would ever
think
less than uh I'm sorry a five-star
review is a problem most people think
that's that's you know that's brilliant
it just gives you an angle I think that
your competitors who aren't using
Behavioral Science wouldn't have thought
of and it's often those under exploited
opportunities that can be very very
profitable
that's a really beautiful sentiment and
that's one of the things that I adore
about learning this sort of stuff from
yourself from Rory from everybody else
that I hear okay so Richard I'm going to
give you enough time to make it to the
pub uh the illusion of choice
yeah where should people go if they want
to pick that up
oh um Amazon's probably the the easiest
place but pretty much any Bookshop with
a online facility will have it and
hopefully quite a few real life stores
but yeah Amazon's easy place to get it
and where else should people go if they
want to follow the stuff that you do
online
so I tweet from at our shotton or if
they're interested in applying this to
their business if you go to
astro10.co.uk that's where you've got my
company website and we give like
consultancy to people like Google and
Mondelez and Skype so yeah that's the
other area Richard I appreciate you and
I'm very much looking forward to our
next eight and a half biases that we
still got excellent and I've built up a
thirst so I'm looking forward to it as
well yeah beautiful all right mate thank
you thanks a lot cheers what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]